[Music]
I hope to pique your curiosity with a
vision to the future of how we might
enhance brain function as we know it and
possibly change our sense of self if you
imagine the brain as this city up till
now it's been as we've been looking at
the city from space we really haven't
had the tools to do anything beyond
seeing what whole city blocks are doing
so you can see what happens if there's a
blackout and and you lose a whole part
of the city what you actually want to
know is what the individual components
of the city what the people are doing
and what's the information that's being
transported from one part of the city to
the other
optogenetics is the ability to
manipulate individual neuronal circuits
refining our vision as a function of
individual circuits and how they relate
to different aspects of our behavior and
if our personality I'm going to give you
a few examples of what's been done with
this technology so far the basal ganglia
is a part of your brain that is damaged
in Parkinson's disease this part of the
brain contains many kinds of neurons and
they're all intermingled if you activate
a certain subset of them with
optogenetics you can make a rat freeze
up and have difficulty walking if you
activate a different subset the rats
start moving faster they take
light-sensitive proteins from very
humble species such as algae that you
find in a pond and can put them into
another animal such as a rat or a mouse
this gives you the ability to control
the activity of your brain cells just by
shining light on them so imagine if we
could use optogenetics or similar
technology to get the input from an
artificial sensor into our brain in
principle we could not only restore
function we could enhance our current
functions so we could give ourselves
ultraviolet light detectors for example
the way mantis shrimps have or we could
take an example from fruit flies and
give ourselves carbon dioxide detectors
and then we could automatically sense
our air quality when things go wrong
with the brain it's just so devastating
I think one of the hopes for
optogenetics is that
if it can work in humans that it might
be used as a tool for restoring brain
function there's a lot of ethical issues
about enhancing your function and making
yourself better this would actually the
whole discussion after my ideas lab
morphed into which was not about
optogenetics or not what we might do but
whether we should do it
that's that's a really great point so
would there be a side effect to
increasing your capacity by 20% it's
really really fun to fantasize about the
future you know in ten years time we
might all be enhanced with with implants
that's the future and it's a future that
should be very carefully considered and
I think what we have right now which is
just the possibility of learning is
actually exciting enough on its own
you
[Music]